we got the story from the Daily Mail Joe
Rogan slams Bud Lights pro-america
commercial release after partnership
with Bill Mulvaney I've heard backfired
and Warren's firm we don't know who you
really are he said what did he say we
don't know you really are here's another
quote in here I want to make sure I read
it they bury it he says uh commenting
it's like the effing dumbest pro-america
rah-rah like we don't know who you
really are now it's so stupid and cliche
it hurts my feelings it's so dumb this
is a company in deep ish that was great
that was from the episode with Jim
Brewer the biggest podcast in the world
and Joe Rogan at first was like oh who
cares about this and then Budweiser
played this stupid and azerbush played
the stupid play and then Joe was like
what are you doing yeah you actually
said it would be way funnier in the
middle of the Clydesdale running and
everything that Dylan came out and like
was like Hey and like that would have
been amazing that would have been
hilarious they needed to either shut up
or like they could double down shut up
or apologize but they're doing this
weird let's try and Pander the people
who are currently really angry with us
it's showing how much they're in chaos
right right like people are saying Dil
mavini's been dark for two weeks it
hasn't posted anything like that's a
very normal PR strategy just say nothing
until it dies and Anheuser bus Budweiser
they're like it's not the worst of all
of them and this is why I think YouTube
is starting to knock videos down because
when the pr 101 doesn't work you go
Brute Force yeah they go to YouTube and
say ban the morels and YouTube is like
let's start using Force against these
people and start striking them if they
have conversations we don't like I found
it insulting like I would consider
myself in the demographic that would buy
Bud Light I don't I don't drink it
myself like my husband would right and
when I saw this pro-american ad I
thought well that's a beautiful
cinematic like artistic piece of work
right like who doesn't feel kind of the
raw raw American seeing an ad like that
and afterward I was like how dare they
try to Pander to me how dare they try to
pacify me with that ad don't pretend to
hold these views when you've taught when
you've shown us what you really what you
really think of us and what you really
want for our country with a much larger
partnership with someone whose ideology
is very much opposed to you know the
these Traditional Values that you're
putting in this ad I it's missing like
the the self like knowledge you need to
see these companies itself be self-aware
if you want to for them to buy their
products and trust them like don't just
pretend like it didn't happen and then
do a binary opposite it's in some ways
more insulting right because they're
taking this moment that was very
powerful back in the day and saying like
we'll just throw out here because
that'll make you guys shut up and I'll
make you guys comply with what we want
the whole thing I don't care if Dylan
has a beer ad I find 21 year old actor
wants to sell beer go for it but a month
and a half ago he was wearing little
girl's dress called Eloise this girl and
pretending to be a little girl and then
a month later was selling beer I'm like
that's where I'm starting to be right
when you sell to kids because that's
like little kids Dylan Mulvaney's
audience is so again the data we know
for sure Tick Tock audience according to
various reports is on average below 21.
which could mean 19 or 20. still not of
legal drinking age and you can make
arguments about college I personally
think the drinking age should be 18
because you're an adult the government
shouldn't set arbitrary standards like
that but uh I'm not okay with the
targeting of children to drink alcohol
when you consider that delmo Benny's
audience is probably much younger than
that Dylan Mulvaney's audience is
probably not 20 years old especially not
21. don't believe in his audience it's
tick tock it's gonna be closer to 14 15.
that's my opinion you're saying that
they knew what they were doing they knew
it would create a firestorm like this no
no they want to Target young drinkers
according to the marketing the the VP
said we need like I'll just put it this
way the left response from personalities
was that they need to Target younger
people to get a new drinking audience
and so they don't want to be your dad's
beer they want to be your teenage
daughter's beer right so they're going
after people who aren't I mean this is
cigarettes all over again yeah
cigarettes get them while they're young
get them hooked for life and so they're
like drink beer kids and it's like no
don't do that don't advertise alcohol to
Children your demographic should be
adults there there's a Bud Light
commercial with Miles Teller whatever
and it's like him and his wife on hold
and it's kind of goofy but it's
targeting adults who are in their living
room and they're waiting for some
adultly thing clearly intended to Target
someone who's in their mid to late 20s
or early 20s and I'm like that's fine
you know he he grabs two lights out of
the fridge and he cracks them and then
he dances over and they're dancing to on
hold music or whatever and I'm like sure
fine that's sickening reality in man is
that college students have probably made
Budweiser so much money from underage
drinking but but hold on and everyone
knows it and people are like well we
can't say it out loud because it's
illegal to sell to them under 21 but the
drinking age should be 18.
but it's so hard on the brain but yeah I
agree I think drinking's bad but I'm
also not about to tell people like how
to live their lives and if you can
listen to the military you should be
able to drink a beer seriously and and
what's happened with the drinking age is
that there's actually been a lot of
teenagers who are at College 19 20 years
old of legal age to to enter to
contracts and join the military they get
drunk and then they don't call
paramedics because they're like oh that
happened to a girl I knew she had
alcohol poisoning yeah actually we she
did get taken to the hospital thank God
and she survived there are campuses that
have specific like if you call us you
will not get in trouble of rules because
this is such a problem there was a huge
Coalition of college presidents led by
the president of Dartmouth saying binge
drinking is such a problem we need to
lower the drinking age because you need
to be with your parents at home when
you're first being introduced to alcohol
and then you learn to drink responsibly
as opposed to this culture that's like I
need to get wasted before I go to the
bar because I may not be able to drink
again and I want to be that's what they
do in Europe
your drinking age is like a lot lower in
Europe that's what I mean that's what I
mean like the drinking age is lower and
it's not it's graduated they'll say yeah
and be like this age hard liquor at this
yeah like a little watered-down wine at
a special occasion it's not quite so um
like off limits yeah people don't know
we like
it's it's not a one-on-one correlation
but kids are allowed to have wine in
church not like you're guzzling it but
in Texas you can drink uh at the age of
16 if your parent is present yeah in
Wisconsin too I think there are a couple
states that have that culture where
again like if you are at a restaurant
with your parent you might be able to
drink I don't know the legality but we
create a culture that teaches people to
drink responsibly as opposed to see it
as a substance that you're not going to
be able to get so you might as well
basically kill yourself this this is a
this is a good one we should read this
it says uh an opinion piece in uh
published in Bloomberg last week
described the move by Bud Light as
setting a new low in corporate courage
quote kicking a political hornet's nest
for collects and Giggles before running
away is no way to elevate a brand or
promote a cause wrote Ben schlot the
Publications advertising and Brands
columnist like I think the important
thing to point out is that y'all
actually had Joe Rogan the first week
then you doubled down in this weird way
and now Joe Rogan is he's in The Fray
and he's like okay this is really stupid
now they let some young active just
marketing VP make the weird you know
sell the beer to Dylan sell the beer to
his audience and then they realize oops
and then probably what happened was like
the CEO of the company's like we're
doing what we used to do make get the
horse we got to open the stable get the
horse should it just come out and been
like Hey we're sorry for sponsoring this
influencer we weren't aware that it
would trigger such a divisive reaction
we won't we won't do it again or lean
into it so hard and I mean you know one
way or the other but did you see that
did you see the CEO's statement though
right after I think that that's what
primed me for being like insulted by the
video is he released this statement and
he's like we didn't mean to step into
such a controversial issue and I was
like do you live under a rock like do
you not realize that that choosing this
political activist based on the identity
is going to spark an enormous enormous
controversy I was like you you had to
know I don't believe that I don't
believe the reports that say that oh
this was a rogue employee or this wasn't
approved like no someone in a
decision-making power at a corporation
like that knew about this I I say it
like this it would be no different
politically if they sponsored Alex Jones
it's not that Dylan Mulvaney is is just
trans some people don't like or I don't
think Donald mulvani actually is trans I
think Dylan Mulvaney is actually
insulting and hurting trans people but
that's a separate issue if they if if
Dylan Mulvaney is a hyperpolarizing
figure who is either despised or beloved
Alex Jones very similar absolutely
despised by the left beloved by the
right Bud Light probably shouldn't be
entering The Fray in politics to this
degree with these kinds of personalities
and I really I agree I think they knew
exactly what was going to happen it's
possible that some people didn't which
is equal it's freaky to me but what I
mean is I don't think they expected this
level of chaos I think they they thought
they were going to get a ton of
attention and right they couldn't stop
it in a second though this I was saying
this I was saying this on my show the
other day I said they underestimate how
forgiving conservatives are because we
are we're not the ones that engage in
cancel culture right we just want we
just in this case don't one vote with
our money we're not saying oh we're
going to write you off for life if they
came out and said hey please forgive us
we're sorry we won't do this again we
realize that it's not in alignment with
what our values have been what your
values are
um then every we would all be like oh
okay no problem like we actually forgive
you if you if you truly repent but the
fact that their CEO was just like we
didn't know that we were being this way
but I I I want to clarify that people on
the culture War right post-liberals
libertarian Etc absolutely should
boycott companies and refuse to to
partake in their products that's not
cancel culture I agree cancel culture is
when you went hey Budweiser we just
found out that 20 years ago you made a
commercial that had an American flag in
it so we are boycotting your product
cancel culture is when you go to
someone's past I agree that's what I'm
saying conservatives are forgiving this
isn't cancel culture this is just
momentary consequences for their
behavior and so it's not it's not a
forever thing like I would never at this
point I would I plan never to buy
anything Anheuser-Busch ever again but
if they come out and apologize for it
I'd be like okay sure yeah I said this
in Austin if they came out that Friday
and said we're really sorry for
sponsoring this individual we did not
realize how divisive this would turn out
to be we won't do it again we we respect
and and you know love all of our
customers and those who enjoy Bud Light
let's get back to just having beers with
each other and not you know being
politically divisive we're sorry I would
have got up on stage and I I would have
yelled Bud light's for everybody on the
house I'm buying do you think it
immediately went out and I don't even
drink do you think they're afraid of the
backlash from the other side of this
like if you said The Goldberg threatened
them right and if you say like we won't
do this we won't ever do the scan like
what are you saying are you saying you
won't have a trans person are you saying
you won't have someone who's audience
primarily teenagers are you saying it's
part of the like I think so many of
these issues no one sponsor Dylan
Mulvaney again yeah but is that enough
like is is that going to seem like a
direct threat to the other side of the
aisle well I I don't care I mean the
other side of the aisle 20 year old 20
year olds and teenagers aren't buying
Bud Light so they've decided to alienate
their entire Market in an effort to
attract teenagers
what yeah this is what I said you have
the ages of 21 to 80. okay where your
marketing beer to these people at
barbecues at picnics at sporting events
and they said the win actually came out
made a video where she was like we need
a new younger audience and it's like
you're at best targeting 21 to 24 year
olds so you're going to take those three
years over the entire human lifespan
that you're sacrificing your entire
doesn't make sense you're talking a
little bit like a businessman that knows
more than I think that the
Anheuser-Busch people know because
you're looking at it just from a revenue
like marketing standpoint I think
there's more at play than just making a
business decision impact investment yeah
I think that the ESG stuff like you
behind the scenes they're getting
incredible pressure especially because
they have been somewhat of a patriotic
company or tried to appeal to patriotic
people in the past like they're getting
incredible pressure from these ESG
systems now these ESG metrics to be woke
not just environmentally but on social
issues that's why we saw those companies
like paying for their employees to go to
different states for abortions like
announcing they were going to do that
because that's being a good corporate
citizen that's crazy right it's super
crazy and that's the same with this I
mean I think this plays into it
exclusive where they uh the woman asks
for a maternity leave and they're like
no but we'll fly you there to abort the
baby yeah like we won't give you time
off we won't give you any extra money
you can't have the kid it just literally
makes sense it's better for us to keep
you as a worker be what's the woman
that's really what it is the the cost of
maternity leave for a corporation is
greater than the cost of the abortion so
these these corporations were offering
to pay for women to travel out of state
to get an abortion because it saves them
money in the long run that's that's
insane because they really care about me
it's because they want me to be happy
they want you to be a CEO get out of
your chair Tim I'm moving in uh no but I
do think that with Anheuser-Busch I'd be
really curious to know what the internal
conversations are like right like I
think you're right there are a lot of
outside organizations that will Lobby
and pressure them but I would also like
to know what the culture is among
employees like have they been
specifically recruiting you know
Progressive lgbtq people who are saying
if you say that you won't sponsor Dylan
Melvin again we will you know turn on
you well I don't know what employees do
at beer companies but you know become
incredibly difficult they must be
getting a lot of very strange pressure
from a lot of different directions this
was Alyssa Heiner's shade is the the
woman who made the call on this whole
this whole ad campaign and she said in
her in her initial in that video where
she was talking about that it was about
inclusivity and we want to be inclusive
and then she said repeated it so like
what does this word even mean if you're
using it multiple times thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8 pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time